all right Daryl
Daryl Lowe where'd you grow up where are
you from originally St Louis Missouri
tell me about your family growing up
St Louis Missouri tell me about your
family growing up oh my family
um my dad
my dad was a gangster he also was a
construction worker
my mom she started off as a nurse
she became a bus driver after this was
all
um after she left my dad I was about
seven years old when she left my dad
and um
it was very crazy I'm the youngest of
four
my mom and my dad fought like cats or
dogs you know my mom grabbed a butcher
knife once
to keep my dad up off her I also grabbed
a knife
and
I stabbed my dad in the back
you know
mom wouldn't come home once
after she had went to work she wouldn't
come home she went to her aunt's house
that evening and my dad you know my dad
was a a serious drug user I also became
one
um she wouldn't come home and
for kids you know coming down off the
heroin
best thing he could do he was pissed he
put all her wardrobe on the front fence
and that night he lit it up our front
yard was
you thought it was
I mean but mom wouldn't come home and
you know they went on and on and on
fighting casting dogs I remember my mom
had us um
on our way to the drive-in and the guy
she was with
he slapped my mom and I told him man I'm
gonna tell my daddy my mom threatened me
before making it back home you better
not tell your daddy but that I told
my dad anyway and that was the insurance
man and I'll tell you this he can't he
wouldn't he wasn't able to slap nobody
else
no he wasn't because my dad didn't play
my dad will blow your brains out and my
dad operated on a team of
treacherous guys you know I used to be
strapped to the armrest before I
couldn't even walk and my snow suit was
stuffed with all of his products you
know my mom's baby brother my Uncle
Harry he was the same made both of them
rest in peace you know but
I mean we went through hell when I was
growing up then you know
I never wanted
after my mom left my dad I never wanted
anybody being her boyfriend I never
wanted them guys there so I used to
steal from their asses every chance I
got out I'd get their ass I never would
steal from my mom because she'll tear my
ass up but
you know I'm back up a little I remember
once my mom had went around the corner
my Dad pulled up in front of her aunt's
house and told my brother
um
come on y'all going home with me my
brother grabbed me me and my brother
went home this was around Easter time
and I was okay as long as that candy was
there in the house
but when the candy was gone I went to
crying best thing my dad could do he put
me in the oven
he put me in the oven to get me to shut
up but I just wanted my mom to come home
right so
man it was just crazy but I love my mom
and my dad I love both of them dearly my
dad rested peace my mom right now on
Tuesday she's 80 years old
and she's in St Louis I'm not allowed to
go back to Missouri
um 95 96
um it was 87 years if I get caught up
again I'm I'm considered to be the
habitual Criminal
if I get caught up again
I got 87 years and whatever else I come
back into that courtroom with and that
came from a beautiful uh black female
judge her name is Evelyn Baker and I
love that lady right to this day you
know I stopped
I did 21 and a half years of my life in
prison first time here three days after
Christmas 85. I got caught out here in
Van Nuys I'm part of the reason they
started calling it carjacking seriously
uh I went to Susanville Chino County
jails Chino West York
uh Susanville
um I came home 89.
um 13 months later I was caught up again
state of Illinois
robberies robberies robberies and you
know little
murder that I've never been called for
but you know
um
I don't look for him to come grab me so
I don't use no names yo I feel bad and
Man look
I've been through a lot you know I hear
voices at times they tell me
kill everybody you see it they didn't
kill myself and you know I really suffer
from that you know I do my best I've
done a bunch of anger management being
incarcerated I've been in uh
uh
what is the um
those crazy hospitals I took site meds
quite a bit ill
and I did a lot of classes man to you
know slow my brain down from thinking
about killing folks there's there's
committing murder weigh on you
yeah
but you know I pray nowadays I pray
and don't throw nobody come in Arms
Reach I try to stay
stay out the way you know I tend to you
know you said 10 this morning so I had
to make myself go in about 2 30 this
morning lay down get a little rest
so I could make it here but what I tend
to do Mark is um
I sleep all day I'd rather be up all
night when everybody else asleep because
I don't get along with people I don't
you know I get into arguments still to
this day daily and you know I don't want
to hurt nobody
anymore but
I'll go there I'll go there
you know like I say as long as
does that come from the way your parents
behaved yes it was you know
growing up man my dad my uncle you know
that's my mom's side of family my my
dad's side of the family my mom oldest
brother he lived in Detroit he was
killed because you know he was one of
those guys that mess with other women
even though he had a wife but my Uncle
Junior he
this guy shot him in a and uh say like
a happy hour spot he shot my uncle
he helped the gun on everybody there
until he knew my uncle was dead that was
the first
craziness you know
went to Detroit they brought their body
back to uh St Louis went to the funeral
I got an ass whooping shortly after that
funeral because my dad felt that I was
laughing over the over the casket but
that was true so he beat the out of
me
you know
I say
they never beat us beat us but when you
do wrong you get your ass toe up so you
know over and over yo like I say I love
my mom and my dad but they'll they'll
tear your ass up and
certain relatives you know um my mom
only had one sister
and my aunt
when we left my dad
we went to her house
um you know this is this this is going
to sound funny remember this Ferguson
Missouri that was my grandson my
second wife Michael Brown
his mom is Leslie Lynette mcspadden we
used to call her Nettie pool and I
helped that little boy once when he was
first born but I had left his
grandmother
and you know last time I was
incarcerated I was in Soledad I called
my mom and sister hey boy you know who
Michael Brown is who the is Michael
Brown
I I didn't know
she said boy that was Lynette's son I
said God damn God damn
and I'm glad I wasn't there there's no
such thing as Ferguson Missouri it was a
neighborhood called Ferguson because
that's where we went when we left my dad
we stayed on the North side you know I
was born in the county of St Louis
Missouri in a small town called kenlock
I was born there and then we moved down
to the city and my dad doing what he'd
do yo my dad did construction work uh he
he helped later a Runway at Lambert
Fields the airport in St Louis that was
a friend
his buddies construction company in the
winter time you know but my dad would
come home my mom would Preston curl his
hair he put his leather leather on
he hit the streets all night
he hit the streets all night and we
never wanted for you know like I
said he said get my son ready he's going
with me and I'd be strapped to the
armrest and backseat of this Cadillac
and I seen it all long before and I grew
up trying to be just like my dad and my
uncle you know and I'd done some things
that I'm not proud of
and like I say I did 21 and a half years
of my life walking the yard and I've
been to some of the worst prisons there
is in the state of Illinois I was in
Menards State Prison yes I did seven
years of minority I did the time out
here and I got out
jumped shipped and came back out here I
was extradited back there and just over
and over and over and over and over do
you have kids of your own huh do you
have children I got two daughters my
oldest daughter she's 39 years old yeah
but I had a son before her he didn't
make it reason being my first wife she
rest in peace she was intravenous drug
user and I waited till I was like 33
years old I put a neither of them on
yeah he used to have hip C I no longer
have that
um what is your drug now I do a little
bit of everything
I do a little bit of everything but I
I don't like to shoot
but sometime I go there yo I go there I
get angry and
man I I
PCP
cracked my drug Choice yo I drink
alcohol I mean I'm a dope fiend man I'm
a dope fan
um
as bad as I want to quit it ain't easy
man It Ain't Easy
how old do you know I'm 59 years old I
just made 59 on Valentine's Day yeah and
you think you'll be down here the rest
of your life oh I don't have a choice
I mean I have no family out here all my
family's in Missouri I got a brother man
my mom's first child he's been
incarcerated since 1977. he's coming
home June 17th I can't wait till my
brother gets out and I supposed to go to
Missouri but I'm gonna go up in there I
gotta see my brother man he's talking me
to sleep at night I came home one day
and my mom house was
complete wreck
where they never found a murder weapon
my brother been incarcerated since 1977
and he's not guilty
he's not guilty I talked to uh he ain't
called me today yesterday when a day
before yesterday he was calling me I was
asleep and I didn't make it to the phone
quick enough
but I told him and sit your ass down you
short come home and you're gonna be all
right come home you're gonna be all
right yo
um a few Decembers ago they told them
uh we know you're not guilty
well how the you're gonna tell me
he's not guilty and you took his whole
life from him
and you know like I told my brother
every time I went to prison I was guilty
not so with you sit your ass down man I
need you out here
and that's part of my that's my worst
pain man that's my worst pain they took
my brother for me
and you know my brother has a different
father my mom wouldn't tell neither one
of us not even my brother
until all four of us was old enough to
understand it and we looked there like
us you're talking about my dad
raised my brother I know that
his dad his name Melvin Hughes I don't
know no Melvin Hughes and I
don't want to ignore him I had to tell
my brother I don't he wasn't there
he wasn't known to raise my brother my
dad raised my brother man
and you know like I say I got two
sisters
and
man my family
my family is
oh all of us got got issues yeah my
sister she bust my head open once with
the Statue of mother Mary because I
called her boyfriend a punk that's her
kid's dad may he rest in peace my
brother-in-law but she's married again
and this is my favorite brother-in-law
he's a deacon in the church but you know
but from uh retired government workers
my sister and my oldest my older sister
retired from CIA she said she couldn't
take it no more the that they
gonna do to
yeah she retired and that's been six
seven eight years now she's been retired
and that's my oldest she's smart as hell
yeah she used to man she's been
everywhere worked for the government and
that was my dad's older sister who took
both of my sisters and hooked them up
with the government when they were still
in high school
I wish that could have been me but I was
like my dad with the family that you
grew up with do you think you had a
chance of walking a straight line
ah
sixth grade I was already getting in
trouble man
sixth grade you know I had a girlfriend
she was a white girl
I totally don't tell nobody that you're
my girlfriend but she did and then
I I punched on when we was on recess and
that that caused me to have to sit in my
conference room for the rest of the year
I couldn't go to class with the other
kids you know I I just I was
I even went to school angry because my
mom and dad fought that night or the
house got shot up you know my dad then
it was drug dealers man so
but a lot of people got killed yo what
do you blame for all the dysfunction in
your family is it the drugs or is it
just the personalities that were
there
and it's a way of life for us man it's
like I say I remember my mom my dad was
together
remember the show
Lucy and Ricky Little Ricky
well that was our family with four kids
me and my brother used to be dressed to
like growing up
my two sisters would be my mom my dad
they stay and you know born and raised
in Cadillacs man and I love Cadillacs yo
I drive Cadillacs you know right now I
don't have a vehicle but my my next bill
could most likely it's going to be
another Cadillac but you know
I like Lincoln's Buicks American-made
cars man I don't want no I
ain't no that you're staying on
skid row now
uh I recently a couple of days before
Christmas I got my housing well you did
so I'm no longer in a tent a couple of
days before Christmas I got my housing
and I'm on the west side
but you know I sleep all day you know
I'm up cause you said 10 o'clock
uh I'll probably be just waking up and
only sleep like four and a half hours
I'll never sleep past that I could be up
two weeks straight
and I'll lay down I'll be back up in
four hours
and I'd say that comes from my my mom my
dad
my mom my dad both of us
at my dad's funeral man
I was living in Oakland
I was feeling killer guy that day that
my neighbors
found me I was I was running home to get
my pistol and I was trying to kill this
guy that was
you know we we got into it around the
corner for where I live in West Oakland
and they said man uh my neighbor's
downstairs man you got to go to St Louis
your daddy
when I got there
my favorite auntie she called me
she said your brother want to talk to
you I saw the he gonna talk to me
and he's locked the up how you
gonna she said no no just listen come
find out my dad had a whole another
family
I got two other brothers and a sister
but I don't
I don't believe in Step nothing
I don't but here it is you know with my
I took care of other folks kids
and didn't get a chance to raise my
daughter
now my son he rests he he didn't make it
he didn't make it his mom you know and
that was my first wife
but she gave me a daughter my daughter
is 39 years old
her name is Dina man I love my daughter
I didn't get a chance to raise her
though but same way my dad did me Dana
was a baby I did it to her I'm not proud
of it and she don't really know you know
my daughter she might call me in the
next few minutes but she
she's doing dialysis today
so when she do the dialysis yo she's
probably Missouri is two hours
ahead of us my daughter might be at home
sleeping my youngest granddaughter is in
the hospital she's as asthma you know
my my sixth self I know I need to get to
the doctor because sometimes my
breathing goes
but then uh I don't go
I'll go but I need to
because
oh no a lot of people I just don't
believe in I don't like hospitals man
but I've been
you know I'll say I'm pretty healthy all
the time I did in prison
I used to be
I'm still underweight
Daryl what would you say is your biggest
regret
holding hurting people
you know I used to ride man I used to
ride I used to kill
but go
uh I don't do this like I used to
yo I'm home now I'm no longer on paper
and I do my best to stay free man do my
best that's why I say I don't really
deal with people I stand out here and
talk to a couple of guys but then I had
to get the off because
eventually you know I'm not a game
banger
game bangers they do what they do but
the way I grew up is totally different
you know if me and you get into it it's
gonna be me and you and I don't give a
about your partners I don't
I deal with them later
but I'm gonna do my best your ass
so I ain't got yeah I'd be looking over
my shoulder that and that's what my
dad and them taught me man you okay they
taught me that so
I asked my my uncle my dad's youngest
brother at my dad's funeral I said Uncle
Mike
how many people you know my daddy killed
he said with my own eyes three I said
well there's nine
that's nine close
in that car
you see it all seen it all my mom she
would cry cry get my son ready go on
with me
I was starting to walk and he still
was dragging us through the mud and
he might give me the guns take that back
in the house to your mama I walk in
there like I was a grown ass man my
daddy said put this up
she could break down start crying I just
looked at her goddamn God
that's my mom man she don't want to
she don't want to remember none of that
and
it's like
I could see it
it's up up Daryl what
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
if I get caught up again
I'll be in prison the rest of my life
and I've been told that I've been told
that in the state California
state of Missouri
and again
um
for the years that I was homeless
I still got homeless behaviors well I'm
just I'm trying my best in my in my
little apartment I'll be walking in
circles trying to
do what I supposed to be doing in the
house
and it ain't easy man it ain't easy I
still have
That Homeless behavior for many years
you know drugs drugs uh
I try to block a lot out I've done a lot
of Anger Management when I was
incarcerated I did a drug treatment
and I did a sap program
and um they really didn't want me in
there because of
my mental illness
but because the lady the psychiatrist
she heard me ask for
a program she allowed me that was you
know one of the psych doctors she
allowed me to go because
you know I wanted to stop I still want
to stop but
I thought I don't drink water
I around gravel
uh alcohol beverage and before I
realized what I'm doing I've been
grabbed some drugs
and I'm just
I
asked him to just take care of me yo be
offensive all around me so again
everybody don't believe in God yeah but
I do
because I I went to God I asked God to
forgive me of all the things that I know
I whatever I can remember
the idea wrong I gave it to God I asked
him forgive me so
I believe he he has but you know
my best friend growing up I was doing a
violation in Illinois
me and my best friend and that's
that's in my second marriage my best
friend had got married
when I lived in California the first
time
and when I went back
um
I went to prison in Illinois and uh then
I was doing a violation over there and
supposedly my friend shot himself in the
head killed himself I don't believe that
right to this day so I had to get the
out of Missouri because I was going
everybody I thought had something to do
with it I was going but I know they come
get nobody with me
nobody but me his mom cried on my
shoulder yo
I still don't believe my friend's choice
he shot himself in the head because oh
me and him used to do
hell no
but again
it was
huh
I'm up
and I'm I'm okay Ben not
with just saying don't bring your ass
back to Missouri
I go if my mom gets sick I go up some
have too much don't with nobody in
my family
my dad
my mom and dad
when their divorce was finalized my dad
said because talk to my babies me and my
younger sister
and my dad took us outside he gave us uh
knows water jugs you sat on top you gave
me and my sister a jug of Peace full of
money
told my sister going back in
my dad gave me a brown paper bag he said
you've done it never nobody with
your mama or your sisters gave me two 38
specials
he said take these home to hide it in
the basement and I did it
I did I knew how to shoot them
too yeah
yeah I know I know how to shoot a gun I
don't do all those crazy these
do I
knock your ass down because they taught
me my my uncle and my dad they taught me
they said boy
they told all four of us look at that
monitor before you open the goddamn door
if you see the man with the certain Ties
on
go get your ass under the bed so that's
how I grew up man and then I started
doing stupid myself
yeah I did it cost me 21 and a half
years of my life in prison
and
I
I'm not afraid of I'm afraid of doing
life in prison not being able to come
home ever again
but
I
just don't bother me
if you come within Arm's Reach
I'm gonna do what I got to do
and you're not gonna
yo guys you know say out their
mouth which is a threat
and it'll let you walk away
well
I'll get your ass because I ain't gonna
let you walk away I'll get your ass
I just asked because I don't want to be
looking over my shoulder so you know
I hope none of the word I'm saying will
cause my first be knocking on my door
I keep myself chained I do Hoops because
I'll be gone
I got to go I ain't trying to go
hey
all right
Daryl thank you so much for sharing your
story
and I just asked who whoever just just
pray for me
and go
go out and jump on my bike I don't know
I don't get along with people man I
don't
I don't
get along with people so I stay the
away and I hope no no run up on me
because I'm gonna try to hurt you and
most likely my heart's going I'm gonna
kill your ass
just don't with me and I won't
with you nowadays
but you know
appreciate you man
all right Daryl thank you very much yeah
thank you